The Joe Rogan Experience yes I mean it
also goes back to the
um to the enlightenment to the idea that
God doesn't exist and the idea that the
human being is this is the is the
measure of all things well if the human
being is the measure of all things what
does that mean our reason and our reason
is completely flawed all of us do things
every day which are unreasonable sinful
wrong and absurd right and the
reasonable person says wait a second
why'd I do that what do I have to refer
to in my confusion and my self-loathing
well the Bible was a pretty good bet you
know for if the Hebrew Bible for six
thousand years right the connect
Christian Bible for 2000 it's pretty
good bet say wait a second let's talk
about human nature you really aren't
that smart you really aren't in charge
of the world you really aren't although
you think you are you think that because
you're human
but God's in charge of the world and
there's a certain way things are and if
you'd like to get out of your wretched
self-consciousness and self-delusion you
better get your ass into church
but don't you think that you know when
atheists talk about religion and they
criticize uh organized religion and
criticize the Bible they they talk about
things that are in the Bible that seem
Preposterous right they talk about
people rising from the dead and walking
on water particularly the Old Testament
right like to use that as a guidebook
for life you have to kind of ignore some
of the stuff that doesn't make sense
well don't you think the Bible's a myth
okay the Bible especially the Hebrew the
Christian Bible comes out of the the
Jewish Bible it's a it's a retelling of
the story in a different way but the
Jewish Bible is a myth and the myth is
the myth of creation and the myth of
Human Experience so what it does is a
chapter by chapter Story by story it
challenges us with disturbing
and bizarre images which says well why
don't you try to understand this
see if you can understand this what does
it really mean to escape from Egypt does
it mean escaping from your inner Pharaoh
what does it really mean to part the Red
Sea so these these stories are told any
myth is a
dramatic retelling of an underlying
reality that can't be expressed
rationally right so the atheists say
everything can be expressed rationally
for example you know that the Earth is
burning up you can tell that because
sometimes things get warmer and
sometimes things get colder you can also
tell that when things get colder that's
obviously because the Earth is burning
up because the sun is melting the
glaciers and the Glaciers are raising
the temperature you can also tell of
course that to be fair to everyone
children change sex you know that don't
you and you can tell that men can
compete as women and women computers men
this is all human confusion because we
trust our senses and we trust our mind
and the mind just it doesn't work real
good we're very cunning but we aren't
very smart human beings and that's the
message of the Bible
and so if you look at um Moses sorry
Moses Moses was they tried the Egyptians
tried to kill them all of his life the
Egyptians tried to kill he didn't have
any trouble with the Egyptians
because God was on his side he had
trouble with the Jews because the Jews
were always saying who the hell do you
think you are
so that's that all the Old Testament is
the story of atheists really saying who
the hell do you think you are
so
when when you're talking about the Bible
right what I mean in the lessons in the
Bible isn't part of the problem is that
your people translated it from ancient
Hebrew to Latin to Greek and all these
other languages and eventually to
English Like A lot's lost along the way
right and a lot is open to
interpretation like a lot of what we're
talking about in these myths and stories
that people take as factual currencies
they probably were some sort of uh
there's some sort of a lesson in the
myth some sort of allegory there's
there's there's things about these
stories that probably have hints of
truth but isn't it hard to kind of
decipher it all can't speak the mother
language that's a very good question so
I wanna first let me ask you okay I'm
going to tell you a story okay okay
these two octopuses walk into a a
laundromat okay see that's what a myth
is I said two octopuses walk into a
laundromat and you didn't say wait a
second octopuses can't walk
well I thought about it but I'm being
polite so what you said is yeah tell me
more okay I'm hoping it's a good joke
okay well I'll get to that but it's the
same thing with the the Bible is really
two octopuses walk into a large but it's
I'm going to tell you a story I want you
to support suspend your disbelief
because there's something in this story
you might get a kick out of you might
and you might there might be some wisdom
in it they might yes and might know but
if you listen
as you would to a story which the Bible
is it's a myth rather than to a factual
retelling you might get a kick out of it
now as far as a translation goes I can
read the Bible in Hebrew I learned I
started learning when I was 40. it's
easy language and there are a lot of
mistranslations uh but the the main
point is not the mistranslations because
there are some pretty good English
translations too but the main point is
saying that doesn't make sense that
doesn't make sense so what do you think
the Bible is do you think the Bible is a
bunch of very wise people got together
and they form these stories to sort of
illustrate the Folly of mankind and how
one needs to have like a moral compass
and guiding principles that are set in
stone and that you have these rules to
live your life in a moral and just way
and that'll make for a better Society
like what do you think the Bible
actually is well a friend of mine Rabbi
was a reform Rabbi was applying to get
into an orthodox
Yeshiva and Orthodox at college and he's
a reformed Rabbi so the guy says he says
you have very good credentials and
you're very well nerded do you think the
Bible is literally the work of God
the Rabbi says no so the guy says well
is it possible robbery says yes guy says
okay you're in right
so the Dennis Prager you know who
I'm crazy about said the other day he
said you know I don't believe in the
Torah the Jewish Bible because of God
he said I believe in God because of the
Torah so if you read the Torah of the
Jewish Bible and the Christian Bible is
just an extension of that you say my God
this is incredible wisdom this goes back
to the beginning of time people who've
tried to figure out everything and they
they didn't have the language that we
have but they had the language that they
had and this was thousands of years of
experience progressed and compressed
into a myth so we know that this is true
because like liberals have always been
in love with the myths especially Jews
with the myths of other cultures
right we say how beautiful it is that
this culture has that myth that the
Haydn Indians say the world was formed
by a large beaver and when the beaver
slapped his tail like that it made the
oceans and when the blah blah blah it's
gorgeous myth nobody says of that myth
wait a second you can't have a beaver
that big
right that's what I would say yeah okay
let's step in and go hey man